televised musical performances bright
red decorations and big meals with
relatives
these are common lunar new year
traditions in china but this year chi
ching is missing out on her annual
family gathering in the northeast
the hotel restaurant manager has been
forced to stay put in beijing where she
works because of coronavirus
restrictions
i feel sad that i can't go home this
year and meet my family but i need to
follow the government's instructions
because we're in a pandemic i don't want
to cause trouble for my country my
employer or my family
chinese authorities are battling to
contain an outbreak of the omicron and
delta variants of the virus which has
spread to 20 provinces and 50 cities
including the capital
to control infections many of the
millions of migrant workers who usually
return home for the holiday have been
warned against travel restrictions vary
per region
testing is compulsory in some areas a
period of quarantine or isolation is
required
this video of a communist party official
warning anyone who didn't comply with
rules would be detained went viral last
week
the controls have sparked complaints on
social media with many users saying
migrant workers deserve to be reunited
with family at least once a year
analysts say they're especially impacted
by covert regulations
a lot of workers
actually they have missed the chance to
reunite with their families for
already two years now and a lot of them
can only
connect with their kids
using the phones and they have not
meet up with their parents and they can
only rely on the phone for quite a long
time
authorities are under pressure to keep
infections to zero ahead of the winter
olympics which opens on friday
in beijing decorations are up but
celebrations are muted and large
gatherings banned
before the pandemic hundreds of
thousands of people would flock here to
ditan park to celebrate the lunar new
year there would be dragon dances market
stalls and live music but for the third
year in a row the iconic festival has
been cancelled
chi-ching will work over the holidays
and plans to celebrate quietly with
colleagues but despite her
disappointment at not going home she
says it's better than spending the
festival under quarantine
katrina u al jazeera beijing